those knees do you hear the rumor about
cowboy Connor I did yeah it could be
sick fight yeah I think I hope can't we
get that fight I think that's a
possibility I think that's a
money-making fight it makes sense for
both guys where's Connor
yeah I don't kind of what's the khabib
rematch but it's like dude let's get one
and then go back that way but you got a
win really I'm not saying Cowboys an
easy fight but it's a better matchup
than could be Bertoni and then Tony
could be fight it's gonna be interesting
to see what kind of talking it's
cuz cowboy did not have a good time with
the talking of Nate Diaz you got
rights that he doesn't like that
Tom doesn't like that don't Connor
goes you guys did that you watch yeah
he's gonna wrap it up to 11 until I
think cowboy if he grabs ahold of Connor
and takes him to the ground Connors in a
world of too
cuz Cowboys a hell of a wrestler however
he's a hell of a striker to me yeah it's
a different it's a different works not
an easy fight to me come on as far as
the the odds I'm assuming Connor barely
be a fail yeah 155 155 yeah look Connors
the the speed that he has the 1 shot KO
power like Connor can do some to
and when you see him fight
Eddie Alvarez that's when you really
realized like Eddie Alvarez is tough as
and Connor just put it on him he
can start he can people up
I thought cowboy put it on every tear he
did but he didn't do it the same I know
he did his legs up he beat his legs up
Connor dis somebody been shots I think
that also is a little misleading because
I feel like a lot of that wrote it was
because Connor got into Eddie's head but
he's better than that look at that
and he's been doing along Conor McGregor
is a two-to-one favorite that doesn't
make any sense to me well it does make
sense that's good at wrestler well it
makes sense based on his last fight yeah
Cowboys have fallen some tough times
I left a beam or anyone in this room to
always fallen sometimes well he's got
the most winning record in UFC history -
I believe so I'm also going by that
hideous one walking good lately well he
looked fantastic
yeah against Mike Perry I mean amazing
but Mike Peck a far cry from Congress a
big different really let me strike what
you're saying but look I like the
fun'ral fighter I like I'd like to fight
a lot and I do agree that if cowboy gets
ahold of anybody on the ground he's got
crazy ground skills crazy just hold on
the Cowboys better off his back if I
want to take him down his ass you'd be
screwed cowboy in tops not a technician
on top no I disagree you think his
technician top top cowboy comes back
cowboy comes back what yes yes but he'll
you up from the top yeah he's got
he's got great time most his missions
are from his back that's true because he
throws a lot of kicks and guys take him
down round just snatched off his back
but he's just he's very underrated as a
grappler yeah you saw many reversed Mike
Perry amazing his arm up
yeah
how about Mike Perry he's not he's he
left Jackson's he's like dude I felt
like it was you know I didn't want to be
part of this yeah you know what came
there to train and all of a sudden I got
put in the middle of this drama he left
he's left
oh no longer there oh he looked great
too
I thought I'd look good even you know
you obviously you had the hiccup of
taking cowboy down but I thought Perry
like pretty good man
ya know Perry did look very good he's
been looking better and better but he
just up until he just that fight
was just cowboy had his number cowboy
sparred with him who knows how many
times L so Jackson's yeah and the in the
grappling apparently cowboy dominated
him but I guess Perry said in when in
the training camp he was taking so many
guys down it's almost like a natural
reaction firm egos did I just part of
the fight took him down daven think
about cuz that's why I was doing he camp
right and then we killed John goes that
was not part of the plan we didn't want
to take cowboy down so